what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we saw episode 2 of The
Last of Us now it is time to watch from
our friend Paul over at heavy spoilers
go check out his channel because he is
killing it he's become The Last of Us
Channel his breakdown in Easter eggs for
The Last of Us episode dos join with me
is the man who I'm covering the last of
us with Andrew Gordon agor 7-Eleven who
you can tell has been hit with a
cordyceps infection with his red eye
today I I am infected you should stay
away from me Greg no no no I got a
special kind of blood
ladies and Gentlemen please go ahead
leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated also uh you can go check out
our reaction for the second episode The
Last of Us that is up here on this
channel John and Tara the non-gamer
reaction that'll be up Manana that is
tomorrow in Spanish in honor of Gabriel
Luna and Pedro Pascal now uh let's move
on to this reaction
[Music]
welcome to the heavy spoiler show I'm
your host Paul AKA not your average Joel
in this video we're breaking down The
Last of Us episode too the series has
had two really good episodes back to
back and is a big fan of the game I've
loved watching these first two entries
They do change some things up though and
throughout the video we're going to be
going over the Easter eggs game
differences and also giving our thoughts
on the series so far huge thank you to
everyone who watched our video last week
I've said that to you so many times
Easter eggs until the end so that people
who haven't played the game can enjoy
the twists and turns that come up in the
show I'll give you a heads up before we
hit that and we start the episode off in
Jakarta all the way back in 2003. if you
cast your mind back to last week then
you may remember that they did an
announcement over the radio that talked
about the city and how summing strangers
going on there yes here we see it
playing out with the outbreak of the
infection being studied by a doctor this
wasn't in the game and I like how the
series is slowly filling in the
backstory of the virus yes both the
beginning of the last episode and this
one had completely new bits in them and
it's possible that we might even get a
story slotted in at the opening of each
entry that gives us way more details on
the infection than what we ever got in
the game now in the game if I'm not a
mistake we don't really know the full
extent of how this virus came to be
right so it seems like Neil drupin in a
conjunction with Craig I want to say
Mason
is working together to actually deliver
for us what the backstory of the virus
truly is and how it all came to be yeah
from what I remember and you guys can
correct me if I'm wrong I think there
was some newspaper clippings in the
video game that said like it originated
out of South America in Mexico or
something like that and so there wasn't
too much context there but we kind of
talked about this too that I love you
know in the first two episodes how they
have these prologues here that kind of
just again explain this and they're done
really methodically and really
interesting and again just give a really
good explanation the backstory to how
the cordyceps brain infection just
started and originated so I love what
they're doing these first two episodes
just filling in the gaps of how it all
started now when the title cosplay shown
we can see this is taking place on
September 24 2003 dating it two days
before the outbreak of course shows how
fast the virus spread and in the game we
learn it was through products containing
flower and yeast which we'll talk more
about in just a bit huge it out to
Dynamic Smurf on our last video for
pointing out that 2003 was potentially
chosen because it was one of the hottest
years in records [__] Heat Wave
happening that killed 20 000 people the
subtitles will enjoy this part of the
show also highly resemble the captions
from the game amazing is more in The
Last of Us world that's a good cast we
shot off with a sunny seemingly normal
day in Indonesia which is when the
military arrive and summon the
scientists to a lab though the world is
stabilized The Last of Us storylines
filled with different militant factions
throughout that all try to seize power
to impose their rule fedrow were of
course a big part of these and I love
how in the backdrop there's always the
idea of Us Versus Them us or them this
is Zachary Naboo who's pretty fearful
that she's been taken in she suspects
they think she's committed crime but
they want it because she's a professor
in mycology mycology is the study of
fungi and she's the top scientist after
having graduated from the University of
Indonesia IBU is escorted Pastor
reception desk and this actually leaked
online when the show was in production
she walks past several vaccine
advertisements as well and these are all
ripping on the week into a poster he
once more get at ham at home that is no
cure and this is why Ellie is such a
Paramount person in the story Nobu
Ratner then examines the specimen and
he's taken to one of the infected that
that we can't show can't show it trust
bloody HBO to have a fully nude woman
they can't bloody help themselves the
woman has a bullet hole in her head and
she clearly only stopped once she was
shot around her foot we see a bite mark
and upon being opened up this spreads
out like the ones from Mrs Adler's mouth
last week
still so gross a really creepy Dimension
to the entire thing now I didn't want to
bring up the clickers last week as it
could have spoiled some stuff for people
who didn't want to know but we finally
get to meet some in this episode out
they don't disappoint either and through
their biology we can see how the
cordyceps work they basically infect a
person and then they spread through
their body slowly replacing themselves
with fungi so they very much become
almost like a living mushroom I mean
it's awesome from Mario he ain't got
[__] on these and the fungus eventually
completely devours their brain and the
upper part of their head this makes them
blind and it's why the clickers are
called that because they use
echolocation in order to see their
surroundings right in the hotel gel
brings up how the majority of the
infected die quite quickly but those
that are sustained go on living for
decades this is very much the case in
the clickers with them being infected
that have been around for decades and
thus the fungus have managed to take
over most of their body and transform
them into these monsters while the the
show match to do two things make it
harder to kill the clickers also somehow
you survive longer when fighting the
clickers in the show Because unless you
got like a ship ready to go you will die
right away yeah it's such a pain in the
ass okay for sure and you made you made
a great point when you're player you're
in control and then when you're watching
these characters there's such more
tension again they just had did a great
job of capturing like wow the clickers
are so much tougher to kill and like you
really feel a sense of danger for our
main characters I love the look of the
clickers on the show too and the body
movements they just really nailed it in
that in episode two I love the way that
the cool decepts are located in the
mouth yeah and it hits at them slowly
taking over the inside but we can't tell
until the infection is further down the
line maybe Rana has a cup of tea and she
learns that things started a flowering
grain Factory now the reason why I think
chicato was chosen is because it
actually has the biggest flower Mill in
the entire world the bagasari flour mill
ranks as the largest on the planet in
terms of size and scale and research
damn that is some real research in here
anyway she refers to it as being the
perfect substrate and in biology this is
a term used to describe the surface in
which fungus lives cheers Google enzymes
here that cause chemical processes and
this may be how the virus mutated to
infect humans now when it comes to how
the fungus spread the game engine is how
it got in the food and a flower and
yeast Factory would be the perfect place
for this to happen when we look back at
episode 1 there was actually a lot of
food that will contain this ingredient
that the characters in the show actually
managed to avoid we had moments where
the younger Mrs Adler made some cookies
and flowers because they had raisins in
them I was thinking we'd make some
cookies chocolate chip raisin uh
you don't need Mr Radler could also be
seen feeding the elderly Mrs Adler and
this could be where the infection
started out at that is crazy sad but I'm
on Atkins
what now which in case you don't know is
a low carb diet meaning that things that
have a lot of flour and yeast in are
completely avoided you know I realized
if Joel were to ever turn if you were to
ever feed on human flesh he would still
technically
probably be on the Atkins diet still
probably but yeah no that was clever I
like that too because we saw in that
first episode he forgot the cake they
avoided she avoided the cookies Tommy
didn't have the pancakes so and all
things had a flower in it by the way I
can't stop seeing Thandie Newton anymore
now that we know that that's her
daughter I believe the correct did I say
it wrong person pronunciation
is tandy oh okay what I just say Mission
Impossible 2 chick how's that
is that good
that work for you yes okay everyone's
best everyone's favorite Mission
Impossible film thank you John Wu now in
the morning Tommy was good that they
weren't having pancakes because Joel and
Sarah had bacon and eggs again they're
avoiding flower products and they also
didn't even have a birthday cake either
so the entire day was them just dodging
bullets there is a lot of emphasis on
the food no I don't know if Joe would
have completely sorry
I don't know if Joel would have
completely skipped I'm sorry I don't
know if Joe would have completely
skipped out on bread when food was spare
but I at least they kept that consistent
he says the woman bit three other
co-workers and that they were all
executed but that they don't know who
bit him and thus the virus is still out
there 14 other workers are missing as
well and there's not really any way to
put a lid on this even if they lock down
the country the cordyceps have mutated
now and it's only so long before someone
stumbles into them when they're out in
the wild oh she says that the whole city
has to be destroyed and we see how this
strategy was adopted worldwide do the
craters later on in the game I was just
assumed they were collapsed part of the
streets due to lack of Maintenance but
you should never assume because it makes
a uh anyway there's no hope and she
wants to spend the remaining hours that
she has left with her family it's a
really Bleak way to intro the episode
and we know that the following 20 years
will likely hell on Earth due to how far
the virus spread it turned the infected
against everyone around them and even
her going back to her family is
something that you'll likely not
experience again now Ellie very much
represents the Hub work here and this is
shown symbolically with a sleeping under
a literal ray of light that shines down
on her gel and Tess sit in the dark
almost like it's a painting of Jesus or
something a butterfly flies over here an
imagery of these have appeared
throughout the series so far oh interest
lies actually carry their own meaning
and typically they're used to represent
rebirth transformation and a change in a
positive direction
and she has the potential to cure
Humanity I love that touch the way
things were where everyone was nice in
the YouTube comments section when you
use what all nice anyway she's again
wearing the same t-shirt that she had on
last week and if you missed that then we
thought it was put on together to Young
Nathan Drake in Uncharted 3. not pulling
that out of thin air yeah it has a
reason and naughty dog made both
Uncharted and also The Last of Us games
nothing but net now they're still pretty
stuff to go over whether she's immune or
not and Ellie ends up having to go to
the toilet she's tossed a magazine and
in the game she ended up coming across
some beauty posters which she was
completely stunned by
that girl is so skinny
oh I never hit that part I thought you
had plenty of food in your time
well we did some just chose not to eat
it this happened just before the hotel
which we ended up visiting in the game
though it appeared way later on I think
there was a scene that Neil druckman cut
out were Ellie's taking a [__] on the
toilet and she's admiring the girls in
the magazines
I want to see that deleted scene like
now I'm really pining to see that like
whoa now you're coming across like a
pervert no that's I was saying you want
to see that so I think I think belly
probably when I say belly that's
bellaranda Bella and Ellie Belly I think
someone said that already I probably go
somewhere but yeah that's funny I I
think she could deliver like really go
into the bathroom because there were
some non-sayers things she couldn't play
Ellie the right way but I think she
could deliver like going to the bathroom
like with convenience and doing it the
right way so I I want to see you around
on a toilet in the magazine yeah I want
to see that this is what we contribute
to the Easter eggs yeah the entire scene
takes place in a piece Salon which
completely juxtaposing the idea of
beauty against the devastation that the
world's now in we see Joel's hands
trembling which he diagnoses as a
hairline fracture after beating the crap
out of the guy last week and trembling
are of course a sign of infection and
it's something that test later has so
you can see why she questions it here
when she returns they in a beating and
Joel and Tess eat some crap bars I think
they're called crap bars while Stelly
has a delicious chicken sandwich this
was given to her by Marlene and it hints
to how important she is since they're
willing to give a what would be top of
the range food in the Apocalypse Now
tying back to the whole bread thing it
is possible that Ellie was given this
because she's immunicordyceps and
therefore there's no risk of her getting
infected good point good point damn who
knows what's in the crops though that
might be me going too far interestingly
though there was a real life case in
France that happened in the 50s that
could have inspired this I've done a
full in-depth breakdown on this in our
video about how the infection started
which is up on the channel now now just
for the cliff notes though there was
some ergot that ended up in bread and
this caused severe food poisoning and
hallucinations there was a man who
thought he was an airplane and he ended
up jumping off a two-story balcony whoa
in episode one The Sign is said that
there could be LSD like hallucinations
given and this could tie back to that
attempted to strangle their own mother
showing how it could affect someone's
rage all in all 250 people were affected
by it and 50 of these were condemned to
an asylum it's a really interesting
story and like I say I've done a longer
video on it but the important thing to
take from it is no carbs till mobs but
I'm on Atkins Ellie says they're trying
to get her to an outpost out west and
there's going to be doctors there who
can help work on a cure Joel really
doesn't believe this at all and we'll
talk in our spoiler section at the end
how this setup what's to come Tess just
wants to finish the job but she's
starting to gain faith in Ellie and we
can see her coming around if Ali is
indeed able to help with a cure then
that would make her one of the most
important people that have ever lived
but it just so happens that she's been
slotted up with some let's say Marley
gray characters
out the way of the door and often you
drop these other ones when escaping in
order to stop people or the infected
coming after you speaking of the
infected I was sure I heard the sound
effect of a clicker when they open up
the door so did I ever did it sound like
that ah yeah
on the same page as you
now speaking of the game they actually
skip over a big section with the two
skyscrapers it was a bit good that we
didn't get to this bit as it's such a
major part of the game early on they
also finished last week's episode by
showing a shot of it to tease what was
to come and there's a clicker oh yeah
that's right there was that moment that
I saw it on Tick Tock yeah where there's
a clip right there bottom left there
this is my first time actually seeing it
in the wide frame yeah oh that is crazy
yeah people in our comments have said
that like did you see the clicker I'm
like what are you guys are the buildings
you guys are making [__] up there's no
clicker there but sure enough there was
a quicker and while I know the
skyscraper scene was a big part of of
the game I really didn't even think
about it until like you just reminded me
about it right now were you consciously
aware of it I was I mean I played the
game so many times it I mean it was I
would have been cool to see it it didn't
affect the the storyline or the episode
it was more of like I was just more
saddened just from a visual perspective
but from a store storyline perspective I
didn't feel it hurt the episode so I
wasn't bothered in that sense in the
video game we get to meet our first
clicker in the the skyscraper building
so I thought like that was a cool touch
whereas in the episode we get to see the
clicker in the museum for the first time
they changed it up a little bit but
again it doesn't like it didn't hurt the
storyline well what they expand on here
sometimes they have to cut out some
other stuff exactly and we might get
some other skyscraper scene later on in
the game there's a lot of skyscraper
related things you got to do now as we
see from the skyscrapers they'd probably
be impossible to climb and descent in
real life due to the angle at the rat in
the game he climbed at one and descended
down the other during the night and this
was all done to escape the federal Camp
as you made your way through you came
across fresh bodies and also encountered
the clickers for the first time after
seeing one grown into a wall this is
something that was teased out last week
and one leaps out at you as you open a
door and you have to navigate past them
as you make your way through this
structure you just wanted to have the
one big clicker scene for the episode
and due to the budget I probably thought
that the museum later on would be the
best place to do without this too is a
location that features in the game as
well with a civil war display being a
major part that we'll get into now in
the game you have to climb scaffolding
and due to one of the skyscrapers being
at an angle they do some really cool
stuff with the physics eventually you
make your way through a train station
and what's one of the tensest parts of
the game before you finally Escape
downtown which is where you sworn by the
infected this is an awesome scene and
they almost grab you from behind the
shutter and I had to hand it to them I
love this moment now in the show they go
the longer scenic route
for the first time looking at the
bombing and what the Government tried to
do in order to stop the spread they hit
most of the big cities like this they
had to slow the spread somehow
so what happened here they bombed the
hell out of the surrounding areas to the
quarantine zones hoping to kill as much
of the infected as possible
along the way she walks past a stuffed
giraffe toy and these actually appeared
throughout the game at several points
they showed up in Sarah's room on the
ground and you don't
and we'll talk about it in that super
spoiler section section section
exclusive spoons and here they make
their way alongside a highway letter
with cars and I absolutely love the look
here really recaptures the game turning
this into an urban jungle where Nature
has taken over once more definitely
Ellie brings up how she got bit and this
happened in a mall inside the qz this
all took place in the Left Behind DLC
and Ellie says that she was just in
there alone which again super spoiler
section at the end we'll also be
discussing some of the infected that she
talks about here and I'm guessing that
this is all setting up what's coming
down the line anyway after hearing the
Cry of the infected they decide to head
into the hotel in the show this happens
much earlier than it does in the game
where they're not appearing until the
Pittsburgh chapter it really managed to
recapture the look of it though with a
central stairwell and flooding being
present in the game you made your way
behind the reception desk and kikachu
Bellboy trolley similar to what we see
in the show there's also a grand piano
channel that makes an appearance and
it's here that Joel talks about his love
for coffee Ali asks if they've ever
stayed in a place like this and Tess
says do you ever stay in a place for my
blood ah no a little out of our league
now this is a no to the line in the game
when they first enter the hotel too rich
for my blood oh fancy
you ever stayed a place like this
too rich for my two Rich for my blood I
guess I remembered it I guessed it good
job Craig thank you brought back PTSD
flashbacks of all those wooden pallets
oh I wish they did that
never again
um just so it's out there I can't swim
well I I don't know how to swim
seriously
I love when they bag on each other and I
think they've included this bit as a nod
to the game and that it's highly
unlikely you'll be returning here again
in the show this kind of sucks as it
also has another big bit with the
infected but you know with the show
changing some bits and adding in others
we might get a payoff similar to that
and they end up ascending which is when
Tess climbs through a gap in order to
unlock a door for them in the game he
grabbed a ladder and navigated your way
up the building which is where you
encountered some Bandits now where are
the things that we ran into which we'll
save for later in case they adapt it
into a later part of the show either way
here they use the time for some
character development with Jill and
Ellie being forced into an awkward
conversation Joel is clearly a close
book at this point and he lies about
where he's from and won't even answer
whether he and Tess are an item it's
important to bear in mind that at this
point in the story Jill's pretty much
just a shell of his former self and due
to the death of Sarah he refuses to get
attached to anything he knows the pain
that comes from loss and his sole focus
is on just making it through the
day-to-day because of his past also
knows that surviving means you have to
do awful things and thus he doesn't
really like to make alliances in case it
comes to a point where it's him or them
standing in the way of tomorrow that's
me and all my friendships and this is a
weapon that she uses throughout the game
now out on the hotel balcony the group
look out and they see piles of infected
yeah way more overpowered than what they
are in the game and we learn that they
have an almost high-like mind due to the
fungus connecting them in the game if
you killed a group of them that was it
and you were completely safe however
here even if you kill one they have the
ability to reach out and call in the
Cavalry the fungi works like a connected
brain and from the vast strains that
live underground they're almost like
telephone wires joining up the locations
can you imagine if that's how it was in
the game it was just been the scariest
[__] in the world of like this level's
never gonna end not only that you would
run out of ammo American Weaponry very
quickly this was a really cool expansion
I was like oh wow never thought about
like this how the the fungus can just
attach to the to the dead and then call
out to the other ones and Signal where
they are because I remember in the game
they were attracted to noise and then
when a certain horde or a certain amount
uh were done okay now you just move on
but whenever like they got attacked by a
certain group of uh Runners clickers or
whatever it's because they were
attracted to the noise or they were
already affecting that area well I think
using this fungi and hive mind way of
communicating is
stronger visually for a television
series because it keeps that theme alive
of that tethered viral connection you
know it has a virus element feel more
contagious just with the fact that they
do feel that much more connected in a
way that is non-human it adds to the
tension like okay they might be safe for
the moment but like another horde can
come at any moment so you never feel
like they're they're safe if one dies
somewhere it can signal is and thus the
survivors are constantly on the Run
trying to get away in the show killing
an infected person doesn't mean you're
out of danger and I love this added
Dimension to them now this massive pile
of infected could also tine with episode
one we of course open with a time Jump
by following a child trying to make
their way to the qz they'd been with a
larger group and it's possible that
these newly infected people here are
where the kid broke off from and they
also use the landscape to very much show
the objective and where you need to head
Moody dog had some incredible level
design and throughout the game you'd
often see where way needed to go
demonstrated by being yes in Boston they
had the girl in down with the State
Building constantly off in the
background which is something that the
show also does too great I've never been
a Boston myself but but I've seen the
golden dome in the department and
obviously it's a sign of status in that
movie so get this so yeah the bit of
info there haven't haven't been in
Boston but I've seen it just talking
about this movie today some TripAdvisor
now realizing they have no other way
around they go to the museum which is
ripped right out of the game in there
there was a wooden beam that fell
blocking a doorway similar to what
happens later on when they get trapped
the game had this separating gel from
tessinelli and you had to navigate past
clickers in the infected back up to them
in it you run into a civil war display
which is something that also appears in
the series as well it was lined with
cases that Hobbit all muskets and rifles
which are another thing that they
perfectly bring across to the series
who's also an officer's uniform and this
appears in the lobby as they step inside
the building initially seems safe
because the roots outside of rotten away
but the open door signal knows that
something else is going on they catch a
staff member grown into the ground
there's also a recently killed soldier
that has been ripped apart Tess is
optimistic that they were attacked
outside and crawled in here to die but
all it does is signal that something
else is in the building now for me
clickers were something that was gonna
make or break this series normally in
zombie stuff you tend to get your
typical grunt zombies and it's rare that
it goes beyond that outside of Resident
Evil and left the Dead one of the big
downsides of The Walking Dead is that
they just kept the zombies and didn't
really Elevate things from there so you
had this repetitive enemy throughout the
click as though they add this new
dimension and playing those encounters
for the first time in a dark room with
headphones on was absolutely terrifying
yup if your so much has made a sound
then they would spring out the darkness
and grab you the worst thing is is that
they were one hit kills if you've seen
the trailer the third trailer the one
that we did a reaction to in case you
haven't played the game on that creature
that they tease at the end that [__] was
is that scary but I play the game I'm
just like running like a madman and I'm
so scared the entire time but they tease
that they're good it's gonna be in the
show and that I cannot wait to see I'm
so excited they're gonna need a lot of
fire for that creature but yeah now I'm
excited yeah on high difficulties even
opening your backpack around them
couldn't let the clickers to your
location and every encounter was as
intense as it can never opened the
Packers
the show has managed to recapture the
tense atmosphere of them and I even
found myself sitting in complete silence
because of how nail biting it was as
they get through the door the beams
collapse and even the shape of how it
falls looks like how it is in the game
we see the mannequins and display cases
and these add extra human shapes to the
surroundings really elevating the
paranoia and fear in this scene one
appears behind a glass case and I kind
of got flashes of the T-Rex scene in
Jurassic Park when they're in the Jeep
oh yeah yeah good yeah that's true let's
do a big fight with two whilst Ali
crawls the way out and Jill uses sound
to distract them in the game you throw
bottles and Bricks but he tips over a
statue in order to draw one away he's
also able to keep his flashlight on and
in the game absolutely none of the
infected reacted to lights because the
fungi just didn't pick up on it Joel
manages to reunite with Ali but the
clicker senses them after they step on
broken glass you had to be really
careful when navigating around them as
there would often be piles on the floor
that could alert them at any second
anyway they managed to take them down
but we later learned that test got bit
during this we're not sure exactly when
this happens but in the game you find
her pushed up against and have to save
her which is when I've always thought
that it happens there agreed now as they
step outside and she sits down we can
also catch a blood stain on her coat wow
my guess is that the clicker pulled back
and then dribble the blood from his bite
onto her right right I gotta say the
fact that Tess was boss enough to get a
clicker off of her you know like an
infected it's one thing you mean a
runner or a stalker but then when you
get to a clicker Yeah the more the more
advanced they are dude we will have
comment from this off the technicalities
I appreciate it you're welcome but yeah
no agreed with you because the higher in
the evolutionary uh gene pool you go the
stronger they are as you as the creature
we didn't mention earlier obviously we
know that's the strongest but yeah yeah
but clickers are extremely powerful and
strong and you know if you don't have a
shiv in the game you're done yeah you
can't push that thing off she gets
infected in the game by a runner but
here the show's implying that she was
able to get a clicker off of her she's
been working she's been working out
that's something that you shouldn't
disregard that I think we need to thank
Robert for that for having those guys
beat her up so much you just got those
workouts and she's like yeah handle a
clicker that's nothing but that was also
really interesting that he mentioned the
T-Rex I think if they wanted to hit us
over the head they would have had like
you know some water with a cup and then
just have it vibrating and then change
the clicker noise tool
sounded just like yeah you're like
perfect you're like Gabriel Luna and
Tommy the you are the T-Rex like spot on
Ali walks past a plank and this scene is
pulled directly from the game after
escaping the museum they have to cross
one are we getting almost identical shot
of that when she makes her way across
the beam Tess clearly now she's on board
time too and she wants them to see the
positive news in her surviving the bite
I like that they added that we get this
line pulled directly from the game
you hope for so is that everything you
hope for
jury's still out
oh man
she had to know that view
[Music]
can't deny that view
hey let's pick it up
I'm feeling something I'd like that they
added them looking at his watch
the game yeah a jail also looks
longingly at his watch this brief glance
that it carries a lot of meaning as it
of course reminds him of Sarah Ali sort
of becomes the surrogate daughter to him
and it's almost like he has a moment
remembering his own life before it all
went to hell this is a really important
scene as the watch of course broke when
Sarah died this was very much when the
World Ended as well and time stopped for
Joel in the exact same second that his
watch broke anyway they make their way
into the building with Joel Still
suspecting Ellie might not be the real
deal shares a bandage to cover her bite
and in the game when you'd pat yourself
up with a Medicare you could also see
bandages like this over the wounds after
arriving at the State Building they see
a truck full of dead Firefly soldiers
and also I think it's worth pointing out
that Joel has an assault right he didn't
get that till the hospital as in the
game I always saw him as being more of a
pistol in shotgun man for moving on now
on the way to the location I came across
a soldier with a firefly logo on his arm
and he had a note detailing that they
were gonna look after the girl inside
they discover the Dead and we learned
that one got bit which led to everyone
turning on each other Tess is in this
situation too and after revealing her
bite they let her handle things on her
own terms Joel is actually a little bit
apprehensive over this and you can see
she comes towards him that he starts to
step back the scenes play out really
similarly to the game with his getting a
few lines of dialogue that marry each
other here
[Music]
foreign
one of them's got to have a map on them
right where was this lab of theirs where
did Marlene say that she was taking out
west Ellie she never said she only
mentioned that it was someplace out west
uh I don't know just west
listen I'm probably gonna get some crap
for this
the one thing I definitively know so far
I preferred the test portrayal in the
show over the game
like especially the actress's voice
seems like yeah you're the kind of woman
I just not that the cat girl in in the
game I want to mess with that version of
tests either but this version doesn't
like yeah you're like super intimidating
right off the bat there's more of this
like wait in history and the way her
voice Community just just a voice alone
I actually preferred the interpretation
that I don't know the actress's name
Anna Torv nice
bring the a game here yeah even just
watching it back to back I'm like yeah I
definitely prefer the actress I mean
she's fantastic I don't know if I'm
ready to say that yeah she's phenomenal
I definitely like the relationship
between her and Joel in the show a
little bit better so far yeah no I mean
it's a fair point what you're saying I
don't think you deserve crap for that I
mean everyone's allowed to have a
version that they they like but we're
talking with fandoms all we do is talk
crap on each other yeah everyone
everyone's we don't respect other
people's opinions and what world do you
live in you make a fair point but again
I like the relationship I like the
history the sense of history and I like
the Romantic history that we feel
between Joel and Tesson and the TV show
a lot better I like the chemistry with
these two a lot as well fair enough
you're wrong
our luck had to run out sooner or later
run out sooner
[Music]
she's infected
I Was Bitten an hour ago and it's
already worse this is [__] real Joel
he's real she just looks so Disturbed
isn't she
her facial expressions are phenomenal
revealing her bite we hear fedra
soldiers storming the area test buys
them some time to escape and he stays
behind to shoot it out with them which
is when he's eventually killed here the
infected are alerted with them
scrambling from the areas
tips over some explosive barrels and
also some grenade so that she can take
them all out it's such a tense scene
watching them close in as she struggles
to spark a pillow so much attention and
her hands trembling because of the
infection Ted has then given the kiss of
death and she drops the ladder taking
them all out now in the game at this
point you descended into the subway
station which is where the fedra
followed you until you run into some
Infected they decided to cut their
losses and leave and it led to you going
further into the underground here though
I actually like the impact and the time
that they give to Tess's death he didn't
really get a moment to breathe
originally but I just love the
devastation that kind of washes over
this scene Joel as always continues
moving but at least a still hit with a
realization of just how quickly things
can change in this world yep see that's
one thing that the show is really taking
advantage of is being willing to shift
perspectives because like in the game
whenever you're playing as the character
you're only in their perspective so
works in the game when tests his whole
death scene actually happens off screen
because you're still just playing as
Joel and early locked so you really feel
like you're in that perspective and
locked in as the player whereas in a
show it allows you the opportunity to
shift perspectives and just focus on
this is only Tess is seen at this moment
you know absolutely and just really
quickly I love to that they changed
instead of the fedra coming in and then
doing it off screen they had you know
stalkers and Runners and all that coming
in and then we get a heroic Sacrifice
from Tess and this was such a badass
sacrifice one of the most badass
sacrifices ever you had time to breathe
on the moment like just to feel it it's
a lot more gut I mean it's still sad in
the game for sure but this is a lot more
gut wrenching because again you're just
so invested in tests at this point it
really is one of life and death and it
speaks about that characters in the game
Ali would even press Joel to talk about
Tess and he'd refuse to because we don't
talk about tests to what happened it's a
devastating way to end the episode with
them now on the other side of the
building and that golden dome hanging
over them in the background now that
takes us into the Super spoiler super
duper trademark greatest of all time
spoiler section exclusive exclusive if
you haven't played both games then duck
out now and also please hit the thumbs
up button on your way out I love you so
we're allowed to talk spoilers Now link
to larger parts of the game initially
when they talk about how the fireflies
are working on a cure Joel says he's
heard this a thousand times before and
he's extremely skeptical over it now
this could be the show setting up why he
does what he does down the line and Joel
eventually gets Ellie to the fireflies
but he learns that in order to make a
cure that Ali has to die thus he turns
in a Rambo and kills all the fireflies
and surgeons before they can operate on
her this line here adds way to him not
believing that it's worth sacrificing
her for sewing that might not even work
and I appreciate that they added then in
the scene Joel also refuses to let her
have a gun when she asks this was
mirrored in the game as well and it was
only after the hotel where she saved his
life that he started to begin trusting
her now the draft toy was also a nice
little Touch Too the end of the first
game has a major scene in it in which
Joel and Ellie come across them and it
shows that though humanity is doomed
there is hope for the rest of the world
Adrian Wildlife has flourished and it's
one of the most memorable moments in
that first game I'm in the PlayStation
classic when they're in the hotel they
get a letter and climb up which is when
they run into Bandits before making it
to An Elevator Shaft here everything
goes to hell and Ellie and Jola could
off from each other which is when you
descend into the basement into what's
one of the most scariest parts of the
game I'm hoping yeah it really was the
stalkers and in it Joe basically
navigates through the basement in what
one of the most tensest scenes of all
time in these dark and Dan Carlos you
run into infected and also blotter which
Ellie touched upon earlier in the
episode she asked if rumors about the
ones that threw two toxic gas are people
were true and this is a reference to the
giant infected that you run into in the
game the longer someone is infected the
longer they mutate and in the last of us
too you come across the Rat King oh
that's the worst the wrecking from where
it all went down and on the day kicked
off they destroyed the stairwells and
ended up locking them everyone's
favorite characters
roughly 25 years it was completely
incredible how messed up he got oh they
also have some neat little nods to The
Last of Us Part Two where the Flies went
beyond appearing in episode 1 and we
could also see one of Joel's guitar and
Ellie even got one as a tattoo yep huge
United ebony Maldonado for pawning at
the shirt lus in the second game is also
the one that Joe ah no way why didn't I
notice that wow this was the next
location where Joel and Ali went to we
discovered that Frank had left and he's
made his way to part of the town that
bill refused to venture to however he
did in order to help Joel and Ellie and
they went into his school to get a
military truck battery this was in there
but they kept pushing through and
eventually found Frank's Body which is
when they learned that he'd taken it
Frank had been bitten so he'd taken his
own life it was pretty heartbreaking for
Belle even if he didn't show it a
judging by the trailers it looks like
they're changing things for next time I
will of course be back for that so make
sure you stay locked in answer my
thoughts on the episode I think it was
handled really well and these two
entries have been the best video game
adaptations that I've ever seen
an aesthetic of the game and every
character is really knocking it out of
the park in terms of their delivery in
action sir plus the clickers were great
too and I love this track through the
landscape of an overgrown Boston that
was full of danger now I kind of wish
they'd done the skyscrab a bit in live
action but I can understand why that
probably wasn't achievable without
completely blowing the budget it's also
the hotel as well which I hope wasn't
the only time that will appear in the
series because obvious locations had
major moments with the infected that I
think would translate so well to the
show I think we'll use those sequences
in other ways Blown Away by it and I
hope we get those bits here fingers
crossed we do now obviously I would love
to hear your thoughts on the show so
make sure you comment below and let me
know I think you have to like use some
more like they would cut out some of
these tent sequences for the show
because you have to use them a little
more sparingly in uh a show or it also
could feel feel more repetitive in the
show that doesn't even sometimes the
complaint with last of us too for some
some players even though I I personally
gameplay wise I agree but story wise
first one for me but specifically on the
gameplay it gets a little repetitive
after a while on a show it can feel that
way so I think a lot of these sequences
that we love will just get like
variations of that sort of more spread
out throughout the show hopefully that's
just my hope but anyway there's another
great breakdown Paul you did it you
nailed it you nailed it Paul constantly
nailing it becoming super successful
unbelievably Filthy Rich alrighty guys
Andrew thanks for being here thanks for
having me heavy spoilers go subscribe
show his video some love as he's got
more videos of Last of Us coming out
that are more than just the breakdowns
all right guys talk with you all soon
keep the lookout for episode three
reaction coming up in a
six days I did math right yeah see you
guys
[Music]